[Music]
i don't think i'm going to be able to
guess the virgin from a lineup here's
the thing just because you're a virgin
doesn't mean you're a bad kisser and
just because you're a bad kisser doesn't
mean you're a virgin i'm just trying to
be ready for everything if people are
going to go in with tongue are people
expecting just like a peck on the cheek
kinky
i think i'm fighting my nerves
my confidence is trying to override
nope nope nope nope nope
i've never gotten a complaint you know
but hey i'm ready let's let's do it
you know i don't worry
any insecurities that was
i enjoyed that i'm pretty confident that
they're not
the virgin i was just like oh
i was trying to ease her
into
what we was about to do you know relax
the situation you know you were the one
who was breathing
i told i told you to breathe too you
know i was fine see i was nervous but it
was good
thank you thank you thank you thank you
i just find this as like a hilarious
first introduction to people like just
telling them how like good of a kisser
they are
you know i don't think i've ever kissed
anybody who i don't know
and so this is like totally new and it's
like kind of
weird and nice there's like a really
soft like sensual like i want to fall in
love with you and probably will
and then there's like i'm coming after
you
and we're gonna like like like just
where i'm at in that moment and like my
intention
oh my god you just
not and just like over you're like
[Music]
i know in the beginning i said like i
didn't want to like offend anyone
assuming that they're the virgin but
like like i'm sorry you think it's me
i have a i have a sentence like it
wasn't number one i have a feeling it
might be you
yeah i mean i will say i don't feel
awkward
you sure yeah
gosh um
i think i'm a pretty good kisser i've
been complimented before i'd like to
believe them i mean i think it's
interesting because the best kisses to
me have been like with the people i
already have kind of an emotional
connection with and like completely
stripped of that i don't know i think
i've annoyed it
your nose is what's cold
there's like some confidence that was in
it i can't tell like if that's supposed
to like throw me off
but like i like it like personally
i
don't know if it says very much about me
but i always love a compliment so
sure it says everything
i honestly don't know it's it's it's
weird i also don't feel like kissing
really brings out that much of a person
i think it's what experience you're in
in the moment and what your mood is and
what their mood is and how well you know
each other and everything like that
but it's been a while it's been covered
it's it's weird
touch your face yeah
i mean like i still think like number
two is kind of up there
one in three we're just so confident and
just like show that level of confidence
that like you would bring to like the
bedroom if you're trying to hook up with
someone this is number four right
number four and number two are probably
like the competi the contenders at this
point
this feels like we're in the lineup of
an improv show i don't know if anyone
feels that way like that's how it feels
for me so it's like i don't know if
that's good for kissing but you know
we'll find out i guess we're not we
don't know what's gonna happen so
hi all right if i put my hand in your
shoulder
yeah number two was really awkward
like in comparison it just sticks out so
much in comparison to like the rest of
them some people could be sweet and
number five proved it or just like you'd
be sweet and go with it it's gonna be
hilarious if it turns out number two is
not the virgin like surprisingly now i
think about it i'm just like leaning
towards just the sweetness level of like
kisses i'll give number two another
chance all right number two do you feel
okay with that
do you want my hand again yeah
same
the thing is like
it's like the thought just occurred in
my head it's so middle schooly to like
just hold your hands like that in my
kiss
like the kiss isn't bad but just the
ambiance is just like
strange
oh my god
i don't think number two necessarily
gives like the virgin vibes the handling
does but like based on the kiss i think
the virgin is
number four
[Laughter]
it was just so sweet
like at first i was thinking that like
four or five were definitely the
sweetest especially like number two like
just taking account of like the case not
like necessarily with the breathing the
ambiance the idea of like what you
perceive a kiss as you know i don't
think
that has to do with appearances you can
tell a lot from a kid i feel like you
know because your personality is going
to shine somewhere your nerves or
something whatever you're feeling in
that moment is going to come out it was
really funny that you said like bedroom
energy because i was like that is
exactly
the opposite of the intention i had i
wasn't confident until number two went
and then i was confident because of
everything she had to say
should have really gone for it now but
as she was saying that bedroom energy if
i were to have experience or something i
would be more
comfortable
kind of if anything just mimicking
versus now i'm just flying
like
guessing this works
it was it was odd but it was fun it was
it was a fun experience
you